what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay well I can't necessarily release
the secret Empire videos until Friday
just because of the fact that we have to
maintain our schedule it does not keep
me from recording them a week ahead cuz
man do I love this story it's the only
way I know how to work out my excitement
for a secret Empire but in the last
videos what we've talked about so far
because we're approaching the end like
we've got maybe three more videos left
and then secret Empire is done which I'm
gonna be so disappointed in because this
story is so good but what we've talked
about so far is that secret Empire for
the most part has basically played out
in three phases
so the first phase dealt with the idea
of Hydra Captain America basically using
civil war to as a way to implement his
own rule in the sense that the superhero
community basically waged war against
one another in the sense that you had a
and inhuman name Ulysses who could see
the future because of the fact that he
could see the future the superhero
community split in half now over the
course of Civil War - there were times
where his visions were a little off they
weren't 100% true but for the most part
they seemed to me now as a result of
these visions Bruce Banner The
Incredible Hulk was killed different
events took place that ultimately led to
this fractured superhero community in
light of that Captain America as a Hydra
agent began doing things like
implementing the erection of a shield
around the planet that would basically
stave off attacks from all but the most
powerful beings in existence and so
because of this this set the stage for
him to basically conquer the entirety of
the United States with the intention of
turning his sights on to the rest of the
world and then eventually the universe
itself now the way in which he was going
to conquer the universe came by way of
the Cosmic Cube the problem with this
was that the Cosmic Cube had become
sentient in the form of a girl named
Holly and the idea was that after being
taken by the Red Skull and indoctrinated
by hydras ideologies Sabich at the
request of Red Skull had basically
changed the history of Captain America
Steve Rogers making him a Hydra agent in
the first place the result of this was
that one of Captain America's agents
really a guy named Erik Selvig it was
kind of the scientists working behind
the scenes to help Captain America
basically fractured the Cosmic Cube and
so what this did is it sent the
remainder of the superhero community on
a mission to try to capture what shards
were left of the Cosmic Cube while
Captain America tried to do the same
thing the problem with this was that
Captain America was a lot more
influential just because
fact that he was using fear and using
the threat of death in order to get
people to hand over their shards of the
Cosmic Cube whereas the Avengers were
relying on diplomacy the result was that
we basically get up to this moment right
now where what's left of the superhero
community is coming together under the
leadership of Captain America Sam Wilson
now the other half of this is that it
deals with the city of New York now the
city of New York had basically
experienced being thrown into a place
called the Dark Dimension or the
dimension of Darkness whatever you want
to call it and it was done by a guy by
the name of blackout who quite literally
was able to just kind of enshroud the
entire city of New York
now within New York he also had like
kingpin you had daredevil but really the
only true means for their escape would
come by way of Doctor Strange who would
attempt to use his magic in order to
help them achieve this goal the problem
with this was that it wasn't something
easily done instead it was basically
Doctor Strange using whatever magics he
could to no avail and so the idea here
is that under these speech basically of
Sam Wilson who had vacated his role as
Captain America following Steve Rogers
basically taking over the United States
and then essentially coming back the
world's superheroes basically have a
rallying point and that's the coolest
thing about this is because as Captain
America Captain America was always a
rallying point it was always designed to
be that way
and so because of this dealing with
what's left of the superhero community
and Sam Wilson racing off as best he can
try to help you know quell this threats
the various superheroes facing off
against the Hydra agents and attempt to
take their country back so to speak what
this does is it basically leads into
everything that's been going on with
Carol Danvers as well as well as the
entire Alpha Flight station now the cool
thing about this is that again this
bounces around from location to location
but with dr. strange remember he's been
going to all these different beings and
in some former fashion tie into magics
and mysticism it's one of the other
reasons why New York being whisked away
we know with dark force energy really
helped big Spencer kind of give himself
a way out of the story in terms of
Doctor Strange himself or at least offer
the possibility because remember just
because of the fact that they're in a
different dimension doesn't mean that
dr. strange is any less powerful than he
was before the issue is can they escape
and that's the nature of a dark a dr.
strange going around grabbing every
single spell that he can muster is an
attempt to basically escape this realm
but he's got his books he's got all
these different things but he just can't
pull
off because in truth the dark force
energy is just far too extreme and he's
just not powerful enough to do it on his
own now remember a lot of this also
comes out of the Jason Aaron Doctor
Strange solo series which is to say
during that story we dealt with the idea
that all magic in existence was
basically being destroyed and that's why
all this works it's not as though Nick
Spencer came along and said we're going
too deep how're dr. strange strictly for
this story instead it's hide directly
into his own story itself in terms of
what was going on with his character
with magic basically being obliterated
the source of dr. Strange's power began
to go away now as the enemy survived I
can't wear what their names were but as
those enemies who were destroying magic
were basically defeated and magic began
to grow it was like a tree right like if
you go out into a field and you plant
the seedling hoping it'll grow into a
tree and you provide some water and you
allow sunlight to hit it you're not
gonna cut out the next morning with a
full-blown redwood tree you're gonna
have to wait years decades in order for
it to grow to its full potential now in
the case of magic it wouldn't take
hundreds of years for it to all return
but it does take time and that's the
reason why Doctor Strange is not as
powerful as he was before because the
source the the energy he uses of the
magic he uses is not where it used to be
and so that's really the nature of his
character the evolution of Doctor
Strange in terms of what it is that he
can and can't do the problem with this
is that while they're trying to cast
these spells try as they might they
cannot get out they cannot get away and
so that's the craziest thing about this
at the same time we also have the
guardians of the galaxy now remember
with Alpha Flight with the forces of of
Carol Danvers and Hyperion and all these
beings who could easily bring Hydra
crashing down to the ground they're all
stranded outside the earth and they're
totally incapable of penetrating the
shield now the attempt to get past it
comes by way of Rocket Raccoon and it's
really cool because Rocket Raccoon
literally shows up and says hey there's
this massive bomb that we have that we
literally stole from another race we're
hoping that we can basically put this
bomb inside of the Alpha Flight station
and then crash it into the shield hoping
to blow it up in the end none of it
works the shield is just as impervious
as it ever was and that's kind of crazy
because while all this is going on
there's things like Doctor Strange
cannot get them out of the dark force
dimension Captain America Sam Wilson and
in his efforts to basically take out the
shield agents is basically knocked
into the ocean and is presumed to be
dead it's almost like this glimpse of
success popped up for their superheroes
and almost when they thought they had a
chance to win they didn't but their one
hope comes in the form of quasar if
you're not familiar with the quasar
character it's easily somebody to write
off and that's usually one of the things
that you hear people who don't know
about quasar people who just kind of
read articles or whatever like whatever
it's quasar quasar stupid it's actually
not true in Fantastic Four Volume one
issue number 552 quasar fought Galactus
to a standstill like Galactus was just
literally trying to kill the Fantastic
Four quasar jumped in and was blocking
every single attack that Galactus threw
out which I think Galactus was in a
hundred state which is when he's as
ravenous and more dangerous than he
normally is so in his worst form quasar
held off against Galactus and that's one
of the things about that character is
one of the reasons why quasar is usually
just kind of looked over and just kind
of ignored when in reality quasar is
insanely powerful now one other thing to
keep in mind is that quasar was Wendell
Vaughn this is a new quasar but the
power is still the exact same it's a
matter of how you use it they're given
these quantum bands which allows them to
tap into an infinite source of energy
and then in turn use those bands however
they want to the question is how far
will their imagination take them in this
instance with quasar coming back it's
almost like Galactus showing up and just
ending everything quasar blast the
shield with enough energy to totally
destroy it this is Universal level power
and so that's why it's so cool is
because again this is not Nick Spencer
just beefing up the powers of a
character and saying oh man I need a way
out we're going to amp up the powers of
toys all we're gonna make plays are more
powerful than they've ever been
just for the sake of achieving this goal
that power has always been there quasars
always been that powerful
it's just how is that power written by
any particular writer and so again with
this scenario with the shield being
totally and completely obliterated by
quasar what it does is it leaves the the
landscape open for those members of
Alpha Flight to come flying back down to
earth which means Deep Ultimates blue
Marvel one of the most powerful beings
in existence spectrum who can basically
become any form of energy
Hyperion all these characters just come
flooding back into earth and now the
landscape is effectively even the stage
is set for the fall of Hydra and so what
happens is we end up picking up with
Maria
now remember if you haven't been keeping
up with secret Empire Maria Hill was
very Nick Fury esque in the sense of how
her character played out if you're
familiar with with marvel bare with me
for a second classic Nick Fury which is
to say the white guy Nick Fury that
version of his character always had
safeguards always had bunkers he always
had these these situations in place so
that if everything went to pot there was
some place he could retreat to and then
tried to defeat whatever that enemy was
but the fact remains that in this
instance Maria hill following the rise
of Captain America Steve Rogers
conquering the entirety of the United
States when underground and what she did
is she became an information broker for
the various renegade superheroes out
there who were trying to find ways to
topple Captain America the Hydra agent
all she did was slip them information
whatever information she could get now
of course that information came from
various sources she had who had been
captured by Hydra in the sense that they
were former shield agents former
superheroes they would pass information
onto her for the greater good which in
turn she would pass on to Iron Man and
his forces now what this does is it
brings the role of Maria Hill into sharp
relief in the sense that she basically
finds a black out now of course black
out being the person that basically
grabbed New York and threw it in the
dark force energy is the only guy who
can basically bring it out the problem
with this is that his allegiances are
still a little off the idea is that with
him working alongside Captain America he
didn't know where this would lead to and
so the result is that once Captain
America used the powers of black out and
then took over the country black out had
regrets black out wasn't sure that he
had done the right thing but the problem
is that black out was never an a-list
villain he was never kingpin he was
never a Doctor Octopus he was never you
know any of these characters who's just
like I know what I stand for I know
exactly what I believe he was a guy that
at the first sign of danger would run
for the hills
and so it was easier for him to
basically pretend to continue being an
ally of Hydra and so in the face of all
this Maria Hill does the only thing she
can do she shoots him in the back of the
head and kills him and in doing so the
spell is broken
New York is free out to the world which
in turn Brees all of New York
superheroes into the fray it starts
bringing in Doctor Strange Iron Fist
Power Man cloak-and-dagger all these
superheroes no matter how popular no
matter how minor are all now returning
and so again this basically continues us
at the stage for the defeat
of Hydra and so what happens here is
that in this moment we also remember
have to deal with the Chitauri now for
those of you guys who don't know who
haven't been keeping up that was the way
in which Hydra Captain America
constantly kept a low flight on edge it
was one thing for them to be stuck
outside the planet Earth because of the
huge shield but what Hydra Captain
America had done is he has also gone to
this jet re race stolen one of their
Queens and brought them back to earth
and then for that reason the Chitauri
were constantly trying to invade the
earth
you know crashing themselves on the
shield and alpha flight was constantly
trying to stop the dattari army the
result is that the Chitauri were
basically continuing to go against Alpha
Flight it was battling 24 hours a day
day after day and they would just send
wave after wave after wave after wave
which would increase a number with each
wave and so again it was just hordes
just bombarding on earth now one could
ask the question why didn't Alpha fly
just stand out of the way and just left
its atari just keep invading earth you
know just keep smashing into the shield
well the issue with that is they didn't
know how well the shield was sustained
their protectors of Earth despite the
fact that they were cast out from the
planet they exist to keep it safe at the
same time it was also a way to draw a
little bit of a little bit of tension in
the story it was the way for next
measure to just say oh man look at how
worn out they are you know that kind of
thing now with the earth superheroes
basically returning with black panther
in Wakanda for example having been
captured for the most part everybody
else staves off as best they can
they defeat every single one of these
Hydra agents or at least attempt to as
best they can and so what this does is
us leading into a crescendo is leading
into this final moment this final push
when everything that Hydra built is
gonna come crashing down but the
question also has to be asked what about
classic Captain America one of the
biggest questions that I've been seeing
down in the comments section is what is
this vanishing point again for those of
you guys who are not keeping up with
secret Empire what we've gotten at well
at least we got at the end of like the
second or third issue and then we've
gotten it interspersed in the different
story so far is someplace that we only
know as the vanishing point and within
this vanishing point is classic Captain
America which is to say Steve Rogers
before he was revealed to be a Hydra
agent classic Steve Rogers so the good
guy the issue is we didn't know what
this was we had no clue what this place
was all we knew is that this was a guy
just wandering around but we had no clue
what in the world was going on he's had
little glimpses where he's basically
recalled his own history his origin
story being a byproduct of the
super-soldier program fighting against
the Nazis during World War two Bucky
Barnes dying against the drone playing
all these different things this intact
history that we know so well all of this
is basically coming out of this
vanishing point and so in this moment
when he sees what seems to be sharing
Carta the sort of ghostly apparition
when he calls out to her when she
basically vanishes what we're told is
that everyone's gone everybody that
Steve Rogers had met up to this point
and the vanishing point is gone they're
not there anymore and the reason why is
because this vanishing point basically
seems to be the Cosmic Cube that this
vanishing point is Kovac herself that
she's the one that made all this stuff
the way it is which begs the question
how does this reconcile these two
Captain America's how does it reconcile
the Hydra Captain America in the real
world and this classic Captain America
in this vanishing point presumably
inside the Cosmic Cube and I can tell
you right now the next video that we do
will answer that man it will answer all
your burning questions it will it's
pretty awesome it's pretty exciting
ah man because like after the next issue
I look at that and I was like well I
know exactly how this story's gonna end
and and it's gonna be amazing
with that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
think what we're gonna do next week is
we are going to cover the secret Empire
the the main story on Friday or next
week what we might do is start to
intersperse some of the tie-ins because
one of the questions people have been
asking me is why haven't I covered like
the invincible Iron Man tie-in why
haven't I covered like the Mighty Thor
tie-in or any of those those are being
done as story arcs and literally those
story arcs end after this issue and so
my idea was all the way to those story
arcs finish and then start covering them
between this issue and the next one
that way we can basically get the full
secret Empire experience especially when
it comes to Amazing Spiderman because if
you've only been reading secret Empire
spider-man shows up in the next issue
and there's no explanation about where
he's been anyway guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]